ر على شاشتنا الان خبر عاجل نقلا عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي يشير الى اصابه 41 جنديا
اسرائيليا خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
فقط هذا رقم كبير ربما يعني يفترض ان تفرد
له ايضا او يفرد له ا تمام خاص
نجوان نعم بالفعل هذا الخبر صدر قبل قليل
مع تحديثات الجيش الاسرائيلي ل ال لاصابات
الجنود في موقعه يتحدث عن 41 جنديا اصيبوا
خلال المعارك الدائره في قطاع غزه خلال ال
24 ساعه الماضيه وبطبيعه الحال هذا عدد
كبير لكنه يتحدث ايضا عن ان هناك اكثر من
2200 جندي اصيبوا منذ بدايه هذه الحرب من
بينهم
355 بجروح خطيره ومره اخرى هذا وفقا ل
التحديث الاخير في الموقع الالكتروني
للناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي عن اخر تحديث
لاصابات ال الجنود واذا ما نظرنا بطبيعه
الحال لاعداد المصابين في الايام الاخيره
الماضيه نتحدث بالفعل عن اعداد كبيره بدا
ينشرها الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد ان بدات
الصحف الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن ارقام مختلفه
مما كان ينشره الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
ولكن حتى الان محمود عند ما يتحدث الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن هذه الاصابات لازال هناك
فجوه بينه وبين ما ينشره من جهه قسم اعاده
تاهيل الجنود في وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
الذي
يتولى مسؤوليه متابعه احوال و وضع الجنود
صحيا ونفسيا ما بعد الحرب وهو ايضا المخول
بتحديد من من الجنود اي اصيب بشكل كلي
بحيث تحول الى ما يعرف بفئه معاقي الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهذا يستلزم بطبيعه الحال دفع
تعويضات مستدامه طيله الوقت لهذه الفئه من
الجنود يتم تحديد نوعيه الاصابه ون نوعيه
الاستمرار في الحياه بعد هذه الاصابه الى
جانب ذلك هناك اصابات نفسيه اعلن قسم
تاهيل الجنود في الاسبوع الاول من الشهر
الماضي في ديسمبر بانه تعامل معها ما لا
يقل عن 18
من الجنود الذين وصلوا اليه كمصابيح عددهم
الى ما لا يقل عن
3000 جندي اصيبوا باصابات وصفت بانها
اضطرابات نفسيه جراء القتال داخل غزه ومع
ذلك حتى هذه الاعداد سواء كان التي ينشرها
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي او قسم تاهيل
الجنود في وزاره الدفاع هناك ارقام مختلفه
جدا تنشرها ايضا قوائم المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه التي تتعامل مع الجنود الجرحى
يعني نحن نتحدث ربما كل مستشفى من هذه
المستشفيات وتحديدا مستشفى سوروكا في
مدينه بئر السبع في النقب وايضا مستشفى
برزيلاي في عسقلان وهي المستشفيات الاقرب
الى منطقه غلاف غزه وهي التي استقبلت اكبر
عدد من الجنود الجرحى حتى الان كل مستشفى
لوحده يتحدث عن اعداد اكبر من مجمل الجرحى
التي نشرها الجيش حتى هذه اللحظه وبالتالي
هنا هناك فجوه اخرى ايضا كبيره بين ما
ينشره الجيش وما تنشره وزاره الدفاع وقسم
التاهيل فيها لجنود وبين ما تنشره قوائم
المستشفيات التي تتعامل مع هؤلاء الجنود
يوميا يوم امس فقط اعددت تقرير وسالت احد
الخبراء الاسرائيليين عن هذه النقطه
تحديدا عن هذا التباين وعن هذه الفروقات
في الاعداد لل المصابين في الجيش
الاسرائيلي فاجاب بان انه هذه الحرب تدور
ليست فقط في ارض المعركه ليس فقط في غزه
وانما ايضا لدعم لرفع معنويات
الاسرائيليين ودعم الجيش في الجبهه واذا
ما تم كشف كافه المعلومات المتعلقه
بالاصابات وبالقتل وبسير العمليات وفي بعض
الاحيان بالاخفاق
التي تحدث في ارض الميدان هذا عمليا يعني
وقف الحرب من جهه الاسرائيليين لذلك هذا
جزء من المعركه التستر على هذه المعلومات
او عدم اظهار كافه المعلومات المتعلقه
بالاصابات وبالقتل وبكل الجوانب السلبيه
من الجانب الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بسير
العمليات والاخفاقات لذلك نرى ان غالبيه
الصحفيين والمحللين العسكريين او
المراسلين عفوا العسكريين الذين يعملون في
وسائل اعلام رسميه طيله الوقت يروجون
وينشرون الروايه الرسميه التي ينشرها
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي لكن في الاونه
الاخيره بدانا نرى ان هناك خبراء وهناك
مسؤولي مسؤولون سابقون امنيون يحاولون
انتقاد هذه المعلومات وينشرون ما هو مغير
لها ايه محمود نعم